[Music]
thank you
Douglas thanks for joining spectator TV
you have written your column this week
on your views about the Iraq War and I
should say conflicting views you felt
around the 20th anniversary back in
March that you weren't quite sure what
to say about it but something else has
happened recently that has prompted you
to write about it this week tell us what
that is
yes that's a very sad death of the
former labor MP Anne clue it uh and
could left the house Commons a number of
years ago but she was an extraordinarily
long-serving and devoted labor MP she
was one of I think it's right to say one
of the sort of slightly awkward Squad
that all parties have who don't fit into
any particularly clear Clique and
therefore don't always rise as as high
up on on the greasy poles perhaps they
should but but and code was a really
remarkable woman and uh not only
represented her constituents with with
greater plan but was also perhaps most
famous in recent years for her
internationalism and specifically and
it's what brings me to write about the
second Iraq war
um her Devotion to the cause of the
Kurdish people of Northern Iraq uh and
clue it traveled to the area after the
unfal campaign in 1988 when Saddam
Hussein tried to ethnically cleanse the
Kurdish people in the north of his
country and she saw firsthand brutality
of that regime and campaigned for
decades not just Democratic rights in
Iraq for all Iraqi people but uh
specifically also to indict uh Saddam
Hussein for his war crimes crimes
against his own uh painful in Iraq and
uh that didn't have any success as it
were until 2003 when people listened to
the case she made in in great silence I
remember in House of Commons when in
2003 she explained what the horrors were
of the Saddam Hussein regime and that's
what brought me to really to write about
this terrible subject again which was
just that the complexity of it at a time
when I think some people from all sides
uh talked about the subject of Iraq very
painful subject for Iraq with a sort of
degree of Simplicity which I think isn't
quite what it Warren and Douglas this
hasn't been and and still isn't really a
left-right political issue is it as
exemplified by the fact that you and and
fluid had very similar views on the war
no that's right I mean as it happened we
became friendly because and traveled to
Iraq together uh because we shared the
same view which was that the Saddam
Hussein regime uh was guilty of some of
the most terrible crimes against his own
people and and other nations of course
remember
that Iraq had been involved in a long
bloody war with Iran in the 1980s has
invaded Kuwait and that it was an
incredibly unstable as well as dangerous
regime uh and Khloe's work included the
documenting of the war crimes and the
crimes against humanity that Saddam
Hussein perpetrated and many people have
left and right felt the same way some of
her obituary notices have noted the fact
that she I think say erroneously have
said she became friendly with Paul
wolford's Donald rums I was not quite
true she met ramsfeld and wolfowitz in
Washington that certainly and and and
they and others were interested in this
and had been beforehand nowadays there's
a sort of uh again there's a there's a
you say there's a sort of left right
thing that people pretend about this is
on all other issues but there were
people from across the political
Spectrum in those days who were equally
concerned about what it was what it
meant for the international order uh to
have a regime getting away with Crimes
of the kind that Saddam Hussein's regime
did and there was a sort of unity in
those days I mentioned in my piece that
uh one occasion anchor and I were
visiting a a Kurdish rights Center in
Northern Iraq and
um I was at least quite amused by the
fact that the
framed photos going all the way through
the the hallway and up the stairs were
of people like uh Paul wolfquitz uh
Donald Rumsfeld uh Richard Pearl then of
the defense policy board
um people who back home in America in
Britain were all viewed with Incredible
uh disdain disgust by that point but who
in this section of Iraq were regarded as
Heroes because they had argued the case
of the Kurdish people among other things
and their Liberation from the tyranny of
the Saddam Hussein regime and as I
mentioned it's just one of those sort of
reminders that you know history is so
much more complex when you're going
through it than when you look back with
all of the benefits of hindsight
Douglas you say in your column that
those who oppose the Iraq War 20 years
ago are not short of examples of how
badly it was botched by countries like
the us but you said that your views have
never been so black and white and even
to this day they aren't and part of that
is due to the experiences that you had
with Ann in Iraq
yes that's right I mean I I was very
struck that there was an enormous
just polarism in those times when people
talk about things being polarized in our
politics today if you remember they were
highly polarized 20 years ago
um but I remember very very struck by
the fact that there wasn't very much new
you could say uh about the rock or quite
quite early on
um even before it began one of the few
things I remember noting somebody saying
that I thought was striking was Ian
McEwen who the novelist who at one point
and I can't remember it's in the novel
Saturday or in one of his cons around
the same time but he noted that that the
anti-war protesters
um if they'd have if they'd have been
aware of what they were marching for in
totality should have marched in silence
now why did he say that because although
there was a very good reason to say
don't go in at all it would also of
course mean the continuation of the
Hussein families tyranny over Iraq
including the inevitable succession that
Uday and qusay Hussein if therefore when
their father died and I was very struck
by that observation of McEwen and I've
always thought the time it was right
but hold that view against intervention
but note that that also has terrible
terrible consequences not least for the
Iraqi people and it's it's just
something I should say echo in my piece
which is uh I think everybody who's
supported the wall have a lot more uh
back then than perhaps admit it now
everybody who supported the war has to
take some responsibility or at least
cultivility for the terror terrible
things that happened in the disaster of
the implantation the post
um the post-war period
and also and it says it's and as well
uh recognize that it was not as
completely black and white as some
people were now painted in red
I mentioned the piece that one of the it
was a on the first years after that the
uh Saddam Hussein regime full and uh
uncle and I were in the north and uh it
were there where Narrows the uh Kurdish
new year was being celebrated this was a
festival that had been stamped out
throughout the summer seniors uh as he
tried to rob the Kurdish people of their
culture and uh here they were able to
celebrate it again
um and and be free again
um for the first time in in years and so
rather at that point McEwen made I say
that I simultaneously can think that the
disaster of what happened across most of
Iraq and the terrible implementation of
post-war planet and also the fact that
in that corner of the country at least
uh it is true that a freedom came which
had not existed before and it I just
sort of think that story can't be lost
and it's one I try to bring out
uh Douglas you had a similar
conversation with Peter Hitchens and
Fraser Nelson on a very old version of
spectator TV about eight years ago and
I'm curious to what extent your views
have changed since then I I totally take
your point that it's never going to be
black or white for you but what do you
wish you knew then that you know now
oh that's a very good question
um
I think that everybody was has to take
into account the fact that the principal
claim of the UK York about wmd turned
out to be wrong and now again it's one
of those things that people say well we
knew that to people but as Bruce
Anderson and others have observed in
past years there's no no particular
shame in taking the word of your
intelligence services and government for
granted on occasion
um and of course the fact that they were
wrong the wmd claim is one of the things
that has caused so much greater
skepticism not just about intelligence
claims but about all claims by
politicians in the 20 years since I
think there have been a lot of
consequences from that
um not least in America with success of
Donald Trump and others who say you know
you can't trust the institutions and
there's there's definitely something in
that uh it's had consequences
um I think that I think the other thing
and the thing that that is being quietly
discussed over the last 20 years is
probably too early still to discuss
among those who are involved but was
exactly where and when the post-war
period went so badly wrong people forget
that there was a period of months where
Donald rumsfelt there was was hailed as
a military genius even by by his enemies
uh I think probably now the history says
that that he and some others who I knew
took their eye off the ball and I think
that was certainly the case uh there was
it was it was it's it's you know I
remember Jermaine Greer saying at the
time and I remember I didn't didn't
highly agree with it but I thought it
was very very interesting point I
remember Jermaine Greer saying the
problem with war is you open Pandora's
Box and you just can't contain it I I
absolutely see the Wizards of a bad
observation of Jermaine Greers and
certainly I and I think others who who
were bullish about interventionism then
having seen what the surgeon was like
have certainly stepped back from from
supporting it again in other words if if
you can't do it well uh don't do it at
all but at the same time I think that
there is just this there's an attraction
that has come since Iraq to many people
on the right and left of a sort of
isolationism and I had anyway still
certainly don't share that I don't think
it's possible or desirable for a country
like America or Britain to Simply have a
domestic policy and not have a foreign
policy as well I don't think it's
desirable to believe there's many people
do particularly right in America now
that is it where we have no right to
feel ourselves in any way able to act in
the world I I don't accept that as being
the case I think the case the cause of
internationalism and the left right
internationalism of the kind that I
included in others represented has taken
a serious battering of late
um but I think that there is also a
battering for being an isolationist as
well I think there is a battering for
those people who believe that you can
effectively let the world govern itself
or police itself or let the UN or other
International bodies be the only
Arbiters I think that view also takes
quite a beating uh so it's an EV it's a
constant ebb and flow that
um I would say that he would just have
to be and I was I'm certainly more aware
myself of the difficulty of navigating
between this Silo and cryptus
Douglas thanks so much for joining
spectator TV
[Music]